hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hooni camstudio the
spiritual successor and not sequel to
huniepop it's not a sequel it's not it's
a game where you have virtual girls and
you flaunt over them
when they're doing their cam girl thing
and if you don't know what that is so as
you can probably tell by the top right
corner of the screen I have played this
before because when it first came out I
wanted to see if it was actually worthy
of me playing it and then I got addicted
to it and then I started playing it a
lot and then I've got a super high score
what are you doing - I know you missed
me okay so I know how to play the game
and I'm gonna fill you in on most of
this so most of these tutorials I'm
actually gonna skip but first we need to
pick our first lady that's gonna join us
in this adventure and yes I've unlocked
quite a few outfits
everyone ignore that fact and they were
and ignore everything that you're gonna
see now it's okay
to flaunt over virtual girls I don't
even think logged over is the proper
terminology for that but it's okay
so first thing that you'll probably
notice is nikki is my girl in this game
she's my jam she is my boo she's my
[ __ ] no but she is super cool in this
one because for some reason and I don't
know why I have an encyclopedia dick
knowledge of everyone in the game's bust
sizes and their real to me there's some
people that's ok it's not weird anyway
so in the game huniepop she had c-cup
boobs and for some reason in this game
she now has bangin double d's so we're
gonna recruit Nikki because Nikki ok
whatever shut up okay I'm gonna skip
this tutorial because I actually know
how to play the game and I want to get
into it so you got your girl she's in
her cute little outfit that I didn't
handpick as I'm creepy I've got creepy I
swear anyway so you put her in the
little spot so now she's working for you
so the good thing about this and what's
important to remember is these girls
have items and fans and they can can so
the whole premise of this one to make it
nice and family-friendly is that they do
Let's Plays in this dark disturbing
building and then they do promotional
photos for thumbnails in this other
building with the camera on it we're
gonna do some promotional photos just
for a little bit then you gotta click
its a click farm game by the way you
just got like you've got a hold down and
click as fast as you can to get as many
things as you can and keep it going and
keep it rolling so you got a Pam I mean
as much as I would like to help you guys
I'm skipping all this screw this screw
this and screw you will meet up with her
back when we have the game be done
that's what we're gonna do because
you're with me now you're on this
journey with me
manage
a harem of girls doing Let's Plays in a
building that's not creepy and they're
gonna be doing the thing selves once you
do enough promotional thumbnail photos
for the girl and she's collected some
subscribers then you you send her to the
let's play building where she makes some
advertising revenue and then you send
her to the computer store where she's
you know the adult computer store where
she's gonna go get some stuff and crap
she's gonna she's gonna she's gonna eat
some sugar she's gonna be going twice as
fast it's gonna be super cool you just
oh god I don't even have enough money by
the way there's an investment screen
where you upgrade all the different
things that you can do for more girls
employed more money more stuff right now
I'm gonna get a second girl going
because that way we can do twice as much
stuff twice as fast and if I wanted oh
it's belly why is belly chubby that
doesn't even make any sense
it's Tiffany or belly belly belly
already has a higher pay rate so I'm
gonna go with Tiffany because he's
adorable and she's good at Let's Plays
and that's all happening here also she
like Tiffany for some reason always was
my errand girl and that's pretty much
the only thing that I had her doing
because one of the most important items
that you could get is the piggy bank
because if everyone has a piggy bank
that means that they for some reason
they have a piggy bank so they're better
at saving their money and then you get
like that you only have to pay them like
half as much as you normally do also
it's very important in the beginning to
do more in terms of getting fans [ __ ]
come on I don't want to do this okay
subscribe pillow the subscribe pillow
also helps because when you're doing
your cam shows it'll actually make it so
that you can
get half as many fans as you would from
a promotional photo shoot as you would
so it's good because it does double duty
and then you can get much more now one
of the six strategies that you can do is
remembering that the initial game it's a
lot slower or it's a lot faster to go
through the cam show than it is to do it
like later in the game because the tamp
the cam show takes very little time in
the beginning that it makes it much
easier to move forward now what else I'm
gonna do is I'm also going to send her
to the boutique get her to shop and that
level up her fashion and that makes for
better thumbnails that other people will
appreciate and she'll be good at doing
things I don't wanna I don't wanna
microphone who needs who needs a logo
headband microphone here and then
that'll be good okay never know if they
can use items yet there we go that's
good yeah I'll give her a look if I give
Nikki the microphone the next time she
goes in to make more of them nails oh I
didn't even give her the coke I mean
sugar Oh goddammit she's going right
into relaxing relaxing
we've got work did you we got to do high
score that we're gonna get and also up
you will never ever ever ever ever make
more fans in the photo studio than you
will from just buying advertising so one
of the biggest things that you need to
do especially in the early game is you
just need to buy advertising because for
some reason it scales like every day
that you buy advertising the next day
it'll cost more but give more fans and
also huge boobs is what nikki has so
that is advantageous to us so we're
gonna take
Oh God so creepy everything I do
everything I do is creepy also I just
got an upgrade that allows me to take
more money out of it thanks I know
so everyone ignore the fact that I'm a
weirdo give me a I don't wanna I don't
want there's really no other way around
I don't want a butt plug I don't need a
butt plug hopefully hopefully towards
later in the game you'll get everyone
coked up after their mind with piggy
banks crossed the board and that's
that's that's how people that's up oh
and she's going to the yoga club she's
going to do Pilates alright so we got
that okay so we got a good bit of money
and the next thing that we do is
productivity because one of the key
components of this clicker game is that
you can hold your mouse down or click
really fast if you want to destroy your
wrists on the buildings that people are
in and that means that you can do it
faster if you get better productivity
and then eventually I'm gonna get since
she's a little a little a little coked
up we're gonna ooh I always liked Kiana
Kyoto was nice Oh God Kiana was nice so
I'm gonna go with Kiana okay so now that
I have Kiana here that means that I can
have two people go into the shop because
for some reason I don't have enough Shh
come on where's the goddamn piggy bank
we don't need this we don't
okay I guess I guess everyone can use
another button good why not why not yeah
a piggy bank yes okay so this is great
because now I have a piggy bank and
hopefully Nicky's Coke ran out now if
not just yet but we can toss that out
the window and then hopefully get
another inventory slot but now she has a
piggy bank
so her pay was cut in half so I can send
her for training again so that she can
get even more fans and now I'm gonna
send uh
I need I need to get piggy banks for all
of them basically that long story short
they need piggy banks because I need to
train them up in the early game when we
don't have a lot of fans we just have to
have we just have to have everything
that we need okay
and you want to go for the specialty
items before you're doing yes because
there yes another bank perfect
better than butt plugs piggy bags are
way better than butt plugs oh I should
have given it I'm gonna cut to the quick
where here's fine here's here all right
okay okay yeah this isn't a let's play
simulator that's not what this is about
I wish it were but unfortunately I hate
to break it to you this is this games
about girls camming with I'm sorry that
I've shattered all of your dreams but I
hate it's it's it's just the way the
world works and it's not you know it's
it is what it is we all have to live
with that
so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna live with that it's gonna be fine
okay I know I've just broken off of your
hearts and realizing that these girls
are going online and being naked and
such
but that's the way it is so just you
know okay we got another piggy bank but
we do we do need to upgrade our hardware
and our web service to be able to just
get more and also more ads more ads
means more everything we need more ads
like those are is sancho I cannot
reiterate how in seneschal so it's
always important to try to speed up time
in the building that the most people are
in because it spreads it equally for
both like it says - - but it doesn't
just do - one on each of them it does -
- for both of them so you want to make
sure that wherever they are they are
doing what they do why do you only have
ten fans this is [ __ ] you need more
fans lady see the more you send people
to go to the do the cam shows the longer
it takes throughout the game so you want
to make the initial ones as valuable as
possible if there's many fans as
possible oh sweet darling oh I've missed
you how you doing
you are always my favorite for some
reason I don't even know why but I liked
you a lot okay so now Lola is on board
and I I adore Lola Lola is awesome and
I'm gonna give her a piggy bank right
away and she's going to let's see you
need to relax everything is fine why
wouldn't it be fine
you don't need to worry about that at
all okay
yeah okay what I need to do now is I
need to make it so that the girls can
have two accessories which is gonna come
after this money that I get and I
definitely need upgrade the money
collection because that just takes up
too much time and eventually I'm gonna
start spam clicking but I'm gonna give
Nikki some cuckoo sugar sugar he's gonna
be fine there and then I'm okay I'm
going into super click mode it's like
slightly faster to do this I'm not
saying it's faster it's just sometimes
this is how I got the high score and I
absolutely annihilated my wrist in a
million ways okay you know what it's not
worth doing that because I don't want to
scream in your ear for the next like few
episodes it stings and yes I've got a
plan
you're my virtual girl anyway let's send
them off to relax and we'll pause for
now so thank you everybody so much for
watching yes I'm going to finish this
game and no nothing's gonna stand in my
way
so thanks again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
I love em no one loved him like I love